on this Wednesday night Nova scotia's
strategy to treat its ailing ERS the
needs of the system have expanded the
plan to inject workers what it's lacking
and the reaction
Canada's defense minister goes to
Ukraine and I saw evidence of
unspeakable Horrors the heavy weapons
Ukraine keeps pleading for and what
Ottawa is promising acquitted facts win
truth wins Justice wins the victory for
Nobel Peace prize-winning journalist
Maria ressa plus spreading their wings
NASA and Boeing join forces for a new
era in flight
foreign
good evening and thanks for joining us
after the deaths of two people who
waited hours in hospital emergency rooms
Nova Scotia is making changes it hopes
will help the strain on hospitals it
includes ensuring those most in need of
urgent care actually get it more virtual
care options and expanding Pharmacy
services from the lack of family doctors
to overstretched emergency rooms and
long waiting lists for surgery health
care across Canada feels like it's on
life support Ross Lord has our top story
on what Nova Scotia plans to do to
revive it and how long it might take
the Nova Scotia government was under
immense pressure to show its Health Care
system is not collapsing for the last
six things over the last couple of weeks
for sure the result a long list of
measures including doctor-led teams
getting patients out of ambulances and
into emergency departments faster
physician assistants and nurse
practitioners providing emergency care
and adding care providers and Patient
Advocates to support patients in Waiting
rooms offering comfort and support and
communication is really essential so
that may be a warm blanket that could be
water and and working in between the
emergency department and the waiting
room so that patients understand what's
happening number one other measures
include acquiring a secondary ambulance
expanding the role of pharmacies in
ordering blood work and offering tuition
rebates for paramedics the needs of the
system have expanded and changed but the
system has not the government says
there's no overall price tag and for
many measures there's no specific
timeline some suggest there's still more
hoping than doing from a government that
promised to fix health care we wanted to
see a plan to ease the stress on the
emergency rooms and we have not seen a
plan to get the people in place to do
that and that is the fundamental
component that's that's missing here
Nova Scotia Premier Tim Houston suggests
everyone in healthcare needs to focus
harder on Solutions my message to to all
the leaders here today was just go like
hell and just just go just get going to
get this fixed strong words that too
many on the front lines are landing with
a thud when I think about what we're
doing at work we're already going like
hell like I can't think about us going
any faster ER nurse Cheryl Burbage likes
many of the ideas but wonders when the
odds of critically ill people receiving
timely care will improve it would be
hard to do any of this stuff tomorrow
right it's you know you still have to
find the bodies to do the work the Nova
Scotia health authority says there's
more Collective will than ever and a
willingness to spend what it takes less
clear as when those investments will
start making a difference Ross lore
Global News Halifax
now to Ukraine and what the country's
president calls A Dark Day a helicopter
has crashed near Kiev killing at least
14 people including some senior
government officials and a child on the
ground
Ukraine's interior minister is among the
dead and he is the most senior official
to die since the War Began nearly 11
months ago the helicopter crashed in
rain and fog near a school in a
residential building 25 people are in
the hospital including 11 children it
appears to be an accident but the
potential for sabotage or mechanical
failure is being investigated President
Vladimir zalanski called it a terrible
tragedy he called the people who died
true Patriots and he repeated his plea
for Western countries to stop hesitating
about providing heavy weapons
the restoration of security and peace in
Ukraine must outpace Russia's attacks on
security and peace in other countries
zolensky addressed the world economic
Forum in Switzerland by video link he
said the supply of Western tanks must
outpace Russian tanks Canada's defense
minister Anita Anand made a surprise
visit to the Ukrainian Capital today and
though she isn't promising tanks she did
commit to sending 200 canadian-made
armored vehicles Mike trolley reports on
the contribution and what's missing
in a tour that only scratched the
surface of the war in Ukraine Canada's
defense minister was still astonished at
the rows of burnt out tanks and walls
filled with pictures of the Dead I saw
evidence of unspeakable Horrors if
anything the visit to Kiev strengthened
her resolve that Canada alongside its
NATO allies continued to support Ukraine
there is a price to helping Ukraine
which includes the weapons and the
vehicles and the ammunition that we have
provided but the cost of doing nothing
is far greater to that end she announced
that 19 million of Canada's previously
announced 500 million dollar commitment
in military aid would be used to buy 200
Senator armored personnel carriers from
mississauga-based Rochelle which
zielinski says they need more than ever
how long will it take for you to fill
that order so we plan to deliver all 200
Vehicles by this coming summer
and this is a very unusual and
unprecedented speed and one of the
reasons that we were chosen among other
reasons is that we're able to fulfill
the project on time of the near 200
Senators already in Ukraine Canada paid
for eight the rest were bought by NATO
allies ukrainians have also asked for
Canada's leopard tanks which Onan says
is part of an ongoing discussion what
the ukrainians want is to have a ongoing
pipeline of equipment uh that is
offensive and you know provide them with
whatever you can provide them with the
um with the tanks with the apcs with
ammunitions with the with the equipment
they're fighting a war for their
existence Rochelle CEO Roman shimanov is
under No Illusion the senator will
replace or act like a tank it was
designed to get in and out of hot spots
quickly which Ukrainian soldiers tell
Global News has made it a popular
vehicle you can see the a lot of
Ukrainian refugees there's also a
personal connection for Rochelle over 80
of its employees are ukrainians
displaced by the war including this
Anonymous welder who took a job at
Rochelle after his mother almost died in
a Russian rocket attack and the Kraken
unit that uh helped her to you know to
survive they basically transported on a
vehicle that her son now is building
he's trying to make a difference any way
he can much like Canada microwave Global
News Toronto
Ukraine has been Relentless in demanding
heavy weapons and it is slowly happening
the UK was the first to announce that
sending 14 Challenger two tanks the
foreign secretary calls it a moral
imperative that it will cost many more
lives and money if the war is drawn out
Poland has promised 14 leopard two tanks
France 40 Light Armored tanks the U.S
has vowed to send 40 Bradley infantry
fighting Vehicles Germany 40 martyr
fighting Vehicles though none of those
are as robust as Maine battle tanks in
Ottawa the liberal government has
quietly admitted it has spent just over
100 million dollars to hire outside
Consultants to help it devise public
policy specifically Consultants from
McKinsey that firm is the biggest of
three international management
consulting firms it gets contracts from
governments and companies around the
world and for a number of years it was
run by a man who was a good friend of
prime minister Justin Trudeau now as
turia isri reports MPS on a committee
are demanding answers about why the
Trudeau government has relied so heavily
on McKinsey and paid it tens of millions
of dollars
the Trudeau government is facing
mounting questions about whether it's
too cozy with the world's oldest
consulting firm McKenzie so why did they
spend so much whose idea was this and
who's pulling the strings public
services and procurement Canada revealed
the Liberals have awarded 23 contracts
worth a hundred million dollars to
McKinsey since 2015.
three of those contracts were through a
competitive process the other 20 were
single sourced meaning there was no
competition these contracts were spent
on things like digital modernization and
other large transformation initiatives
it's not clear what value taxpayers are
getting um you know as with any
consulting firm they're going to pitch
that their Wares are better unique
proprietary in departments May well go
for that call this meeting to order a
House of Commons committee is now
looking into whether taxpayers got value
for what they paid for and whether there
should be an investigation you know we
want to know exactly what the processes
were for procurement was there
preferential treatment and if there was
it's going to open up certainly larger
ethical questions
there are ethical questions about
McKenzie it's been involved in scandals
in South Africa China and the us where
the company agreed to pay 600 million
dollars for its role advising businesses
on how to sell more opioids during the
drug epidemic the Liberals have a
challenge since they've been in power
the essence we charity so this sense of
yeah being embedded with uh uh you know
business uh actors so private companies
or wealthy people prime minister Justin
Trudeau says he welcomes the committee's
work and defended the use of Consultants
I think people can understand that
professional Public Service needs to
make sure that it's doing the things the
best way to well serve Canadians and uh
regularly draws on outside expertise the
committee wants Dominic Barton to
testify Canada's former ambassador to
China chair of the government's 2016
advisory Council on economic growth and
once the director of McKinsey the chair
thinks this points to a broader problem
of the government's overspending on
outside contracts it's ridiculous it's
not a good use of taxpayers money
from what little return we are getting I
could go to anyone in a grade one class
and get the same answer committee
members voted unanimously to launch a
review members also want to hear from
cabinet ministers and examine McKinsey
contracts going back more than 10 years
Donna Victoria Israeli in Ottawa tonight
thank you big news in New Zealand prime
minister Jacinda ardern is resigning she
says she'll stay on no longer than
February 7th she says the job was the
greatest role of her life but she's out
of energy I know what this job takes and
I know that I no longer have enough in
the tank to do it justice
it's that simple
ardern became leader of New Zealand's
labor party in 2017 at the age of 37 the
youngest in the party's history she was
elected prime minister in a landslide
she easily won a second term in 2020 a
general election will be held October
14th a decades-long fight for Freedom
coming up the case of two Saskatchewan
sisters behind bars for a murder they
insist they did not commit and the
newest satellite in orbit what it could
mean for us Earthlings
two sisters in Saskatchewan who say they
were convicted of a murder they didn't
commit we're hoping to be released from
prison today they spent 30 years behind
bars a federal ministerial review has
been looking into their 1994
second-degree murder convictions today a
judge reserved his his decision on
whether to free them and the crown is
opposing their release as Melissa
ridgeen reports a powerful voice was in
their Corner today pushing for their
release
well I first met them when they came
into the prison system I was the
national director of ephrai at the time
and uh very quickly a number of other
women said you know you should work on
this because there's something the
matter with why these these women end up
ended up here Senator Kim Pate has been
fighting for these two Soto sisters for
as long as they've been in Canada's
prison system 30 years for a murder they
say they didn't even see happen Pate
Left Behind the Senate chamber in Ottawa
to come here yorked and Saskatchewan 200
kilometers Northeast of Regina asking a
judge to release narissa kuzans 48 and
her sister odelia while a federal review
determines if they were victims of a
miscarriage of Justice goes talking to
my oldest daughter Haley and she was
mentioning she was like wow Mom you're
51 today and you were in person 30 years
and four or five years in a boarding
school so I've been confined most of my
life the sisters were just 19 and 21
back in 1993 when they went drinking at
Anthony Joseph Dolph's farm with their
their 14 year old cousin they say the 70
year old propositioned the sisters soon
after he was beaten and stabbed to death
something this cousin admitted to while
he was free after a couple years in
youth jail the sisters who maintained
their innocence have been in jail since
1994. odelia is now at a halfway house
while narissa remains in custody both
nurissa and Adelia I think deserve to be
out from under this a senate report last
May calls for the exoneration of 12
indigenous women including the cusant
sisters saying they're victims of an
unjust system stacked against them
Justice Donald lay hasn't said when
he'll make a ruling on their release
more time on top of the 30 years they've
already spent Behind Bars Melissa Ridge
in Global News Winnipeg
this week two first nations in Canada
announced the detection through ground
penetrating radar of what are described
as anomalies at the sites of former
residential institutions much more work
and investigation needs to be done and
with the number of discoveries expected
to rise there is a growing push for the
federal government and for churches to
help in the process by releasing key
historical documents in their possession
nithu garcha reports more than 170
plausible burials detected on the
grounds of a former residential
institution in Kenora Ontario survivors
like the mother of the nation's Chief
Chris skeed were the ones who led the
search this is the second time that I've
ever heard or speak of
the residential school I'm 51 years old
she's in her late 80s he says the
community's next steps include using
cadaver dogs to search more wooded areas
we're going to be looking at still
commencing more searches this discovery
has changed everything it's the second
such announcement in a week after star
blanket cremation in Saskatchewan said
more than 2 000 anomalies were found
along with a child Jawbone near a former
residential School site there in
downtown Vancouver survivors are
gathering this week for a National
Conference held by the office of the
independent special interlocutor for
missing children and unmarked burials
Kim Murray we want to know how many
children died in Indian residential
schools we want to know what they die
from we want to know where they're
buried critical elements of that work
are school records still held by Ottawa
and various churches many have been
turned over but she says there are clear
examples of Records still in the Federal
government's possession that survivors
have been unable to access the children
of shinwak have been trying to get
access to treaty Payless to identify two
of the boys that they know drowned at
the at the shinwak school in Sault Ste
Marie and Canada has refused to provide
those records to them Survivor Phyllis
webstad and founder of orange shirt day
says she's attending to stand with
others I'm here to support the families
that do have loved ones missing and
she's highlighting how the institutions
severed the ties through which culture
was taught and sustained resulting in a
loss of traditions and language I wish I
knew my language
so that I could have words
to properly describe
my feelings and what's happening at an
event focused on what Murray calls the
pulse of a revolution data is power
and who owns the data has the power and
it's about indigenous people taking back
their data and taking about back their
history
and that's the Revolution by connecting
the facts in those documents to the
truths of survivors
Global News Vancouver
you can see the full interview with
Kimberly Murray on our website
globalnews.ca a reminder there is
support for survivors a 24-hour crisis
line is available for anyone
experiencing pain or distress as a
result of their residential school
experience you can call toll-free and
speak in confidence the number is
1-800-721-0066
[Music]
legal Victory ahead what Nobel Peace
Prize winning journalist Maria ressa is
celebrating
a big legal victory for a Nobel Peace
Prize winner in the Philippines a court
has acquitted Maria ressa and her online
news Outlet rappler of tax evasion a
decision she calls a victory for press
freedom
today
fat win
truth wins
Justice wins
the country's Court of tax appeals ruled
the prosecutors failed to prove rappler
evaded tax payments over a 2015 deal
with foreign investors ressa believes
the charges laid by the Philippines
Department of Justice were a politically
motivated attempt to muzzle reporting
about the country's violent War on Drugs
she calls the decision a Triumph of
facts over politics
this acquittal
is not just for Rattler it is for every
Filipino who has ever been
unjustly accused
rappler and ressa still face other legal
battles including a separate tax case
and an appeal filed to the Supreme Court
over an online libel conviction the
charges were laid during former
president Rodrigo duterte's
Administration ressa is a vocal critic
of duterte who led a brutal war on crime
that saw thousands killed it also
triggered an international criminal
court investigation into possible crimes
against humanity
future of flight next NASA and Boeing's
green partnership and how soon it could
take off
[Music]
[Music]
another Falcon 9 rocket launch from
SpaceX today this time carrying a Next
Generation GPS satellite into orbit the
Satellite by the U.S space force will
help modernize and enhance navigation
Services back on Earth the rocket
carrying it nailed the landing on
spacex's drone ship while the satellite
continued to its destination
well the name NASA makes many of us
think of space but the second letter in
NASA stands for Aeronautics and today it
announced a new engineering design
focused on making Aviation Greener as
Mike Armstrong explains it could
drastically change the way airplanes are
built
tend to take a lot about flying for
granted there was a little change to
Wings Over the last couple of decades
you likely didn't even notice Wings went
from this to this that little upturn at
the end is called a winglet it was
originally NASA technology and made
planes more fuel efficient well there
may be a much bigger change to Wings
coming they would get longer and have a
truss added underneath that is a
revolutionary design and this
is going to be flying
in 2028 the new design was pitched by
Boeing as part of NASA's sustainable
flight demonstrator competition on
Wednesday it was announced as the winner
NASA is putting up 570 million dollars
for the project Boeing and other
partners will add close to a billion
dollars more
there's a hearkening back to some early
aircraft older planes sometimes had
multiple Wings to add lift the new
design makes Wings longer for the same
reason it's so long and thin it has to
have a brace
but you can actually get lift on this
brace as well as the wing
the old concept to the old biplanes the
goal is to produce a test plane and have
it in the air within five years if
everything works out the technology
could then be added to new aircraft
Construction in the 2030s along with
other improvements the hope is it could
increase fuel efficiency by about 30
percent nasus is the deal with Boeing is
about helping the aviation industry not
just a private company this vehicle is a
path to validating technology that's why
we're doing this we're trying to
validate technology we're not trying to
to build a commercial product here this
coming year will be important for the
Boeing NASA partnership for another
project the spring Boeing's Starliner
spacecraft is set to make its first
mission to the International Space
Station with a crew on board that'll be
somewhat more traditional NASA news Mike
Armstrong Global News
and that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your candidate is the view from the
hills of Caledon British Columbia thanks
for watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]